This emoji is a total shit show. Apple completely
butchered it and it's actually kind of a big deal.
Think I'm being dramatic? Think again. This
is the lotus flower. It is a sacred symbol
in a lot of religions, including Hinduism and
Buddhism, and it has a deep history in a lot
of Asian cultures. The lotus symbolizes purity, a
beautiful, unstained flower rising from the mud.
Here's Apple's emoji, which looks nothing like
a lotus, more like a water lily, which isn't
even in the same genus as the sacred lotus.
Lotus flowers grow on a stem above the leaf,
not floating on the surface like a damn lily.
And I know Apple likes their cute notches,
but lotuses don't have leaf notches
like this. This is a different plant.
There is a water lily that is called Nymphaea
lotus, but it is not sacred in Asia, which
matters because searching “Buddhism,” “Hinduism”
or “India” on Apple's keyboard brings up the lotus
emoji. Searching “water lily” doesn't. Google
and other emoji designers didn't make this
mistake. So how on earth did this happen? And
who can connect me to Tim Cook to get it fixed?